[Music]
in PR stunt news Hoover right
submitted by you won't pick this but you
might so what we picked up and now we're
on the Semitic good job your five
seconds of fame or a porn site that each
a porn star getting bit by a shark why
are your underwater photo shoot okay
I thought that I didn't know staged did
it look real me oh I thought it fit but
yeah a looker [ __ ] all right so this
is allegedly staged because as of now it
hasn't been confirmed that from the porn
sites that it has been staged to be
clear I'm sure alright so I'm going to
show you guys this video this course are
her name is Molly Cavalli she is 35
years old terrible names yeah it's not a
real name well she the point and I'll
tell you the terrible point what would
be a better point be a good wife except
anonymous you know maybe poison no but
there will be a lot more popular to do
well you shouldn't have multiple porn
stars with the same name but Molly's not
echolalia stupid alright so she was
shooting for cam soda and a shortcake
look at that deep blue scary water here
we go looks beautiful
like shark sightings have shown up
shifted idea
oh we want to talk like that sharks are
pretty scary another cool shot
what do you go to the kini like that oh
my god protect banging that is pretty
scary if I'm going on you feel more we
see your feet are from the bottom of the
cage yeah and that's why they shot it
oh that was real so that's the video
that was my Robin at the end does she
get like hot there's something that's
why she looks pretty fun uh-huh
whenever I imagine like she's like that
and the guy comes out with the fan days
of [ __ ] it's like let me make sure that
you're okay Thanks oh you know thank you
I think that's how it was a typical
storyline cancer they uploaded this
video and in the description they wrote
that this model was bitten while
broadcasting from broadcasting live from
the shark cage and they're saying that
the broadcast has to be cut short
because Molly's foot look out of the
cage and was bitten by a lemon shark
according to them oh those look very
docile
yes exactly and they also mentioned that
she had to get 20 stitches but that
she's in good spirits and on her way to
quick recovery that's what they put in
the description of the video
what exactly is camp Sona porn site it's
a webcam oh well council man okay he
knows where that meets another corns I
know how we know that that's very real
it's because the acting was really good
mm-hmm porn actresses are absolutely
terrible and if that was her acting she
needs to get out of porn I start doing
movies really cuz I sure I don't sense
the opposite I thought like man
occurrences really really chilling I
thought a clown's creature but that's
how white girls cry yeah they all high
like that oh my god man she getting
foster she crying I know a little bit
low she's right
red blue maybe maybe that's a [ __ ]
sharply yeah yeah I thought her acting
was pretty good yeah so the drill team
she acted better than half the youtubers
acting Yahoo
pretty good after the picture of Molly
and which is cute yeah that's pretty
deep dude that's not fake at all well
they're saying like shark eyes first
we're saying that that really was a shot
- especially from a lemon tree
she would have like multiple all the way
their teeth are sakes she's not crazy
and she was wearing thin oh yeah that
doesn't make sense
oh she's a really good actress but if
she was wearing fins maybe the rest of
the punctures are in the fin and who the
[ __ ] are they to know if it was a lemon
shark or not hmm
well uh they're important people with
what they did cleared up by doing this
lookee here [ __ ] you know huh this is
a [ __ ] bite are you [ __ ] kidding
me
excuse me ha yes this um an owner and
operator of Florida shark diving told a
news outlet that Molly and her film crew
had previously approached him two months
ago about doing a shark dive and faking
an on-camera injury so that's why
they're being accused of faking it
because of this man coming forward and
so he's saying quote I was talking
directly to Molly and she just said hey
we're looking to do a shoot faking a
shark bite and it's strictly in order
for it to go viral then he says we
immediately declined we are pro shark
Pro wildlife and want to show the
importance of Sun on millon eyes them as
dope so apparently another boat boat
company are they Asian I don't know
probably problem with Toddy's enemies
couple you know we put them in soup
anyway so so why does anyone care oh
just cause it's a cure so it was
recently surfaced that the fact that
this man came forward saying like well
she hit me up two months ago oh she
wanted to create a video specifically
for it to go viral
what have you just a crazy shark liver
mousse like I can't have sharks being
seen in this life let me lie and say
they came to meet students but her
budget I love realistic I wanted to stay
in porn the multi-billion dollars so cam
soda has they haven't made any
statements about this new accusation so
I don't
of course they have it because I like
it's very now it does anyways after
something like that I don't know
makes me feel Keith's hot I don't know
part of it after they go viral then then
what happened I think we got a chance
mother how did you notice how nobody
knew Sam soda would that's right that's
true all this talk about can sort of a
lot here on drinking news because people
were thought that I damn she's hot and I
can watching a [ __ ] naked okay Miss
Molly Ringwald oh yeah no hole that's
sixteen Candles eighties actors most
them don't [ __ ] I think on there I think
it's just like a because it need a flash
type [ __ ]
oh alright okay or I could see her naked
live what's the point of that you look
up some pictures faint yet right it's
not like the print exactly that you you
go on campus I have not but I do think
there's a difference like when one when
one girl sends you news you had her nude
but you always want her to send you more
like it's not enough to go back and look
at the ones you already receive yeah
okay becoming a fire yeah I think I
think it's already and you're going to
see the same thing but it's probably a
little different of an angle that's
right and the only time you Rhian joy
them is when you forgot about them and
then you see it again yeah that's right
oh yeah cuz you see them when you look
at poor and like you can't look at the
same thing and it's boring yeah you used
to it
you got to recycle after a year it's
like oh that's right this was the og one
yeah I can see why live isn't important
okay this is a good man right understand
she knows what's up mmm-hmm yeah but
that cage looked a little bit too open
and a little too small for my taste
yeah it was like that's a dangerous
thing to fake because those shards
weren't that big and those openings work
yeah they just opening was like let's
say this big and just was her body so
she just went through it like that I
didn't I didn't like that because the
cage that you guys were in was a literal
key yeah it was that was oh no the holes
are still pretty big for my like I was
still
yeah but I was uh I did think it was
fishy I didn't think it was fishy when
she got into the cage with fins on
there's none of us did
oh yeah well because you're not going to
swim anywhere you're gonna having fins
on this is gonna make it harder for you
to climb we did open a snorkel but no
fans it's not like this is really weird
why - why sure that's important - yeah
and you said - like when the the the
longer fins only work well once you gain
a certain amount of motion yeah right
because if it's that in a closed space
you would have shorter fish or if you
had fins but you probably even happens
this is interesting having a life jacket
makes more sense because you could just
kind of hold onto the bars and get
deeper and let go and just go faster
surface having fins in that area we're
not going to swim those making sense
right they'll make me sound a creepier
than normal but we sure she had fins
because I only remember today
so was the big as he had been and she
had a very aerodynamic bathing suit she
was very attractive a bit depressing
because I like geography of her face -
the snapchat filter ah it's the only one
I have I could try googling no because
if you do that there's a big porn
popping yeah yeah you can't compares or
any [ __ ] up yeah but I don't know so
let's pretend that we didn't know she
staged all of this because this story
went viral in fact that porn star goes
into a shark cage gets bitten it's like
oh my gosh is crazy what are you
thoughts on that I don't think the porn
star needs to stage and it didn't go
viral
yeah if a porn star just started a vlog
channel I can't deny that
yeah and they'll all I would want in the
crazy lives right I'm actually not the
PI flying around going to expose banging
doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ] living the
fast life stripping doing [ __ ] like that
like I do not be a crazy-ass life to
watch are not even I've already applied
the opposite from people that are like
entertainment they're more the pokies
[ __ ] reserved or whatever but I still
would like to see because I feel like
the people that they hang out when it
would be like really attractive it's a
duality of it and especially the top
name one they're probably hanging out
with other death metal band drummers or
something and hanging out with like BMX
bike riders
you know what I dislike is to park them
every porn star girl sounds just like
that I'm gonna go into a chart time I
don't I don't want them just guys like
talking normally you know like what they
could do that on the video but when
there's like hey guys so today I'm just
gonna go into a shark king night look
dying those exist they just not publish
that I thought of those okay thank you
it depends on which acting school I went
to to I think I know the only person
they talk like that like I am it two of
them on a music videos you're a newer do
still talking and then they're really
like quiet and like to themselves and I
wanted yeah there was a video that I
shot with Paul one of the girls was a
corn star and I completely miss guests
because I didn't know which one was
because they all look like porn stars to
me I was like so the one that I thought
was a porn star was actually just a
model the version I was like that [ __ ]
the porn star she [ __ ] loud as hell
if you don't forget like touching
everybody yeah he said a lot big wasn't
was the quite one that was very serene
and calm and very sweeping to you yeah
she was porn star did you guys enjoyed
that episode of just continues if you
did please leave a comment down below
and sheriff's just Austin your feelings
for more episodes click right up here
[Music]